um that is a high-level overview of the
issues it is a high-level draft plan
that is out for submissions um
and i think the key message is really
that it would be useful to have a more
in-depth process with local government
and manafenoua to make this process as
useful as possible
when does it cease to be a draft
sorry when does it cease to be a draft
um i'm sorry i don't have the exact date
when they're attending to publish it
thanks
so there are four recommendations
receiving the report noting the
draft national adaptation plan out for
consultation
noting a draft of the proposed regional
submission and confirming that we wish
to be included in that so with that high
level overview and apologies for the
fact that you have been able to read
through it in detail
i'm happy to move or test the meeting
and move the full recommendations uh
look for a secondary counselor sopa
and open for feedback if anybody's not
comfortable now is the time to to
register that or if you wish to support
it counselor sopa
thank you mr chair i i do support it i
think it's a a useful thing for us very
useful thing for us to be involved in
but because it is still in draft form i
just want to make the comment
some of the sentences in the draft are
quite convoluted
rhiannon has given us a very
straightforward explanation of the
points i just feel there is a little bit
more drafting to really give this the
punch of a submission that is going to
be
read and taken note of
so i just want to make that comment
thank you
any other comments
reverend cook
just because i'm really nudish
the ministry for the environment is not
to kawana tango aotearoa because that's
the government as a whole it's manato or
thank you
note that
other questions or comments
or nerdisms
if not i'll put it to the vote all in
favor aye aye aye aye against
carrie thanks for that rihanna
right that brings us to the annual plan
deliberations and we'll start off with a
correction on what i uh
incorrectly put out as the process for
before
um
[Music]
as to
today the 14th of june and the 28th
which is when the rate is struck
rihanna do you want to run through that
process just so that everybody's clear
on it and and give it to us correctly
rather than the version that i did
so the process today is to deliberate on
what you've heard from submissions and
the updated information that's included
within the report around the financial
position as well as the options put
forward by officers so you'll see in the
final recommendation which is number 15
it notes to recommend to council to
adopt the plan incorporating or not
incorporating so it may well be that by
the end of these deliberations you get
to the point where you are ready to
recommend to council to adopt and then
essentially the decision making for the
annual plan is complete if there are
further options that haven't been
considered that need further
consideration or you don't reach final
kind of
decisions on key points today then there
is the option to consider again on the
14th of june
on the 14th of june you will also
receive the report on fees and charges
schedule and adopt the fees and charges
schedule on that date
and you will receive the results of the
consultation and deliberate on the
roaring 40s consultation which will be
input as well
and then
the
annual plan will be adopted on the 28th
of june by council
um
so that is broader process it eclair is
there any
other element you wanted to mention at
this point no my question to the chair
in writing was whether we would where
the council would wish whether officers
would recommend the council
adopt the annual plan on the 14th
whether that would get you a head start
on
financial work for the incoming year
we would be able to do that with the
exception that we need to finish the
roaring 40s element which will then be
incorporated
thank you
right if we go through it uh section by
section
for discussion purposes and questions of
clarity then we will go through uh the
recommendations um uh after that
councillor club
yes chief just wanted to um
clarify what was just said by rhiannon
and and like
by chief executive um
bringing forth a date to adopt the plan
to the 14th of june means that today
we have to be happy with the information
in front of us and i'm certainly not in
that position so i can't speak for
others
so i think your advice to start with is
the way to go
work your way through the advice on this
paper come to the conclusion at the end
yes we're comfortable to uh
reckon to adopt the plan or alternative
we need some further information
i agree we would be at a better
place to understand what shape of
meeting we'll have on the 14th of june
at the end of today councillor podinger
thank you look um again just some
clarity on when would a member
say give us 10 cents worth on the
entire
annual plan thing
you know rather than going picking bits
by bits
if you just wanted to give a
when would be appropriate time for that
well i'd like to go through
and and give people the chance to ask
questions for a start and i'll go
through it section by section right um
and then feedback and comments at the
end once we get into okay so i'm looking
at the recommendations
if you have any questions before then
by all means stick your hand up
rihanna we're in your hands where would
you like to start
so if we start with the overview of
forecast financials and the forecast
rates increase i'll just run through
some of the headline points and
patricia's here to answer any specific
questions you might have
so
essentially this overview is split into
two sections that talks about the
differences between the ltp
forecast for 22 23 and the consultation
draft forecast for 2023 and then it
talks about the changes following
consultation as a result of quarter
three reforecasting
so it's just split into those two
sections
so you'll note that there was a shift in
the capital expenditure
from 45.4 million
in the ltp
and
110.9 million operational expenditure
and by the time we went out to
consultation
you had been through the process of
looking at all the issues in that table
which has headed changes from the ltp
and that resulted in a change to
72.6 million capital expenditure and
115.9 million operational expenditure
so that change resulted in a change in
shift in the rates from 4 to 7.78
at the time of consultation
now for the eagle eyes amongst you who
might note that all those elements
within the table don't add to the
difference in the operational
expenditure i will note that that
difference is the depreciation
so you'll recall that
a revaluation
during the time since the long-term plan
resulted in a change
of
the value of our assets and therefore
the costs of
depreciation so
those headline elements within that
table were what we consulted on with the
community about the changes that have
been seen as a result of changes in the
economic environment and changes to the
decision-making that u.s councillors
have made on a number of key projects
included including city street stage 2
and the preferred option for the museum
so i won't go through all the other
changes in that table but those are
familiar to us and to the community from
consultation
over the time of the consulation period
then reforecasting were complete
so as a result of that reforecasting
there's been a small further change to
the forecast capital expenditure and
operational expenditure moving up to
74.2
million capital expenditure and
116.4 million operational expenditure
but you'll note that that change
actually results in a small drop in the
forecast rates increase
to 7.15
so all those changes are listed below
i will just touch on them briefly and
then if you have any questions we'll be
happy to take those so the first one was
a correction due to modeling for
infrastructure
which was as a result of the significant
change to the rating approach made in
2021
so the correct amount of revenue has
been raised but essentially it's a
problem within the budget model so
that's been incorporated
city streets stage 2 was not included
within the ltp but was separately
consulted on at the time that we went
out for consultation the whole amount of
the rates increase that would be
required for that project was included
in 2223
so now we're proposing spreading that
out and that balance actually more
accurately reflecting when the work will
take place so that reduces the amounts
of the rate increase required next year
there's also been a change
to the government subsidy revenue so
that's purely a timing of when that
money has come into the budget and that
results in an increase within this
current financial year and a decrease
next year so that just has to be
factored into modelling
there's been a change to the solid waste
revenue and expenditure and this is
around changes that we're seeing flowing
through now
over the time of lockdown increased
amounts of waste coming through
and
increases to the emission trading scheme
costs
there's decreased revenue from the
building consent services
reduced capital forecasts
in particular relating to those three
water projects discussed above
and an accounting area in the double up
of the water supply repairs
as a result of quarter three forecasting
there has also been some savings which
officers have been able to make across
the
accounts
so that explains why the shift in change
since the time we consulted reducing the
rates increase from 7.78 to 7.15
so if counselors have got any questions
on that overview at this point thanks
rhiannon just before we go to questions
i'll just observe that the video for the
live stream
has once again frozen but the audio is
continuing i'm not going to adjourn and
allow it to restart the audio is there
and for those that are on the live
stream and still listening
thank you for your persistence that's
the way it's going to be i'm sure you
can do without our visual gorgeousness
counselor clark
mr chair rhiannon just a couple of
questions on what you said um
the government subsidy i've already
asked this question but i'd like you to
clarify for me again if we've got the
government subsidy coming in for shuttle
ready
and three waters work
if the the money comes in in this
financial year which is 20 21 22
but the workers
does not either
undertaken or not completed until a
future year i don't understand why we've
got a potential surplus one year and a
potential deficit the following year i
mean it's standard practice and all
sectors including local government
sector to use contingent liabilities so
um and i'm not i don't know why that
isn't explained but for those who are
listening in a contingent liability is
where you get money in one fiscal year
and you can
from an order perspective carry it
across the end of a financial result
at the end of june to allow you to make
payments in the following year which is
when those payments
um occur so i don't understand why we
don't have an explanation of that
patricia can you give an answer i can
give an explanation to that councillor
the um funds in question we now do
believe we have expended them so can
recognize them as revenue in the 21 22
financial year
it was planned that we wouldn't be able
to because that project hasn't hadn't
started but they've actually spent the
money on
pipes so we can apply the government
funding towards the pipes
so so we don't have any
unders and overs at the end of the year
is that what you say that's what the
current forecast is
does that answer your question counselor
it does
and the other question for me uh which
is a lead into further questions further
down the track when we consider the
4.4
increase in the uh long-term plan
and we're now looking to a
7.15 increase
what's that uh just want to know what
that extra 3.15
is in dollar terms it's my understanding
it's somewhere between 2 million and 2.1
million there's one affirmation of this
that's the level of increase that we're
trying to find
are you able to answer that on the hoof
patricia or would you need some time
it's it's just around this between 1.8
and 2 million on the hoof
thank you
further questions councillor no i'm
happy with that at that stage thank you
councillors any other questions on that
section for rhiannon or patricia
if not we'll move on to the next section
thanks random
so the next section of the report deals
with the feedback from the community as
part of consultation
so i've split this into two sections um
the first is on the towner southern
museum and art gallery and the second is
other on other options to manage
the rates increase you're just a
reminder that the results of the
consultation on the fees and charges and
on the tisbury reserve are coming in
separate reports
um so really the main takeaway from the
feedback from the community on the
southland museum and art gallery was
that the council's preferred option the
larger new build was also the preferred
option from the community that was the
more chosen option
with
option one to redevelop the existing
buildings still remaining a
pretty popular choice
i think that
this report also deals with some of the
specific concerns and queries
around
how the projects will actually be
delivered that i've pulled up here for
you
to consider in terms of how the officers
are planning for those i won't go into
those
in detail i'll just
probably
draw your attention to the fact that
really what the public were wanting to
see was a do it once and do it right and
so that's probably the question for
consideration
later as you come on to um
the
um assessment of the options and what
makes best sense to you as councillors
the other key message coming through was
around delivering it getting it open as
quickly as possible but there is no
difference between the options on that
matter
so
i will leave it there on the feedback on
the museum unless there are any
questions on that
councillors counselor clerk yes thank
you chair um rhiannon i just want to
backtrack a little bit onto the long
term plan
in the long term plan we offered
the community two options one was to
restrengthen the museum
and
get it open
and we've got 72 percent of those that
um
made comment about that and it's quite a
large capture group
i said they wanted the museum
strengthened and reopened
the other option we gave them was to um
to do nothing
and to consider other options which only
got a support of 20
so why didn't he refine
and
um
so i guess in some ways
the annual claims only got a small much
much smaller number of people um
coming forward and it just seems to have
gone
and we've picked up i like councillor
partner and counsellor
arnold both raised earlier on about um
you know we get feedback from from
people we just go off in another
direction so just wonder what our what
our view was that we've now really
gone down to the new museum option
because the as you quite rightly said
the issue is they wanted something done
quickly in the new museum not a quick
fix
just like your views on it do you wanna
have a crack at that round
i think you make a good point counselor
clerk about the lower numbers submitting
in this engagement i think that is very
much a reflection of two things the
timing of the omicron um pandemic and
also the
fact that people feel that they have
shared their views a lot on the museum
that is why within this report i've also
included more detailed information on
that broader engagement to give you an
assurance of of that those wider
conversations that were taking place on
social media
and at the farmer's market so i guess
the only other point i will make is that
when we had conversations with people at
the farmer's market that obviously the
question of timing came up
and i think people once they understand
that all options are essentially being
delivered in the same time frame
you cannot deliver option one any faster
than the other options then
people were considering that issue as
well
thank you councillor lewis thank you
chair rihanna just so i can
get it straight in my mind exactly
council clark's point perhaps
option one basically do nothing
with either strength will do nothing
option two
the
hero version option three a a good
version also
but the natural fact that if you loosely
say there are two options do nothing do
something
the figures for option two and three are
you to do something about it or grasp
that with grossly
higher percentage than
a high percentage of the total votes i
see where you're going with that
counsellor but i don't think the
community interpreted option one as do
nothing i think they didn't interpret it
how council meant it which was to
renovate and
re-develop the existing building but as
you say while noting the serious
limitations with that option
yeah so the figures for option two and
three combined were greater than were
yes mr chair um
would it be fair to say that the
way people have responded
within the annual plan is because of how
highlighted to inuit was in the annual
plan and that respect that there was
substantial
amount of what we sent out
um including the imaging and all those
sorts of things as opposed to being part
of the long-term plan but also that it
had a much more concrete
process and
imagining if you like
that went along with it and that
includes how it was presented at the
farmers market and places like that
it's see
it seems to me that when i looked at the
long-term plan
the
the place of redeveloping the museum and
that was much while it was there it was
not quite as
um
alternative focus as it was on what do
we do
with nihota tanifa
as opposed to what might some other
thing be that is my as i was a member of
the public at that time that was my
perception of it and i wonder if that
has colored
the responses
that we got back once it was singled out
in the way that we did in the annual
plan process
i think what what you can take from it
is that there were good was good
understanding
on both occasions of the options and
actually the options were quite
different
in the first consultation it was
renovate the existing building or
do nothing and boost up haywarketeria in
the meantime to give more time for a
solution
now the options were to renovate the
existing building or
to build a new build
and i think
what if if i may give my feedback on
what i saw from the public that these
the subtlety between the sizes of the
two new build was the part perhaps that
the public didn't wasn't able to engage
with us effectively but when they were
clear on the choice was between either a
new build or retaining the existing
building then i think you can be quite
confident and the results here were also
backed up on what you see in social
media and in conversations that the new
build and do it once do it right was
what the public was saying
thank you
councillor edmundson
thanks cheer
um i guess one of the things that
surprised me with the feedback that we
got about the um the difference was
between option two and three was
actually that people didn't really seem
to appreciate or realize the risk
involved in going with the council's
preferred option over the 65 million
option
because that risk is around
the need for external funding because
there was actually very little
difference between i think the weekly
rates for the 65 million option was 3.22
and for the other option it was 3.30 a
week so a very little difference there
for an extra 10 million dollars but that
was because that 10 million was mostly
made up by external funding which has
been pointed out by the staff to us as
being the significant risk
um i'm wondering whether perhaps we
didn't necessarily highlight that
as well as we should have to the public
but i'm also wondering whether that
risk profile has changed at all because
to me that seems like
the difference between whether
option two or three is the preferred
option going forward
so i'll
provide a response to the first part of
that question and then perhaps steve i
can't actually see him but he might like
to answer that second point with that
question
so i think firstly
i agree that on reflection we could have
put
more clearer messages up front about
risk i think though it's very hard and i
don't know realistically what difference
that would have made risk as a topic is
not one that human beings relate to very
well um and when you're doing an
engagement like this we're trying to
provide as much clarity over what the
differences are between all the options
it was described at various points in
the consultation document
but i agree we could have said more
about that
look in terms of the second part of that
question has the risk changed at all
have we got greater confidence around
funding
uh can we manage the risk of council
through uh 11 million or 20 million
dollars
uh the answer is nothing's changed in
our advice
we still believe that that poses the
significant risk for this project
and that's why our officer advice which
is further on in the report that's why
that hasn't changed
because nothing in the external
environment has given us the confidence
that that money is going to be easy to
get
we recognised too and that was certainly
one of the flavors of the consultation
that you heard from the community is
that
the economy is having an impact on
everyone and as a result we've left our
recommendation from staff at the same
point that we left it through the
consultation
document process
can you ask another question
so i guess uh following on from that in
terms of the operations of
a 65 million museum and a 75 million
museum is there a significant difference
in that
um
because i assume that adds even more
cost and risk going forward
yeah um
i think we can't we probably could come
back to that later if you want to keep
working through rhiannon stuff i don't
want to take the thunder out of that
but certainly there is an operating
difference
and we've noted in the report again
that
the larger facility will cost a lot more
money to run
and that'll all be opex
and actually the amount of time and
effort we'll need to spend filling
those special galleries for touring
exhibitions
we haven't worked through all the
details there and so there is there is a
degree of risk on that as well and
we will be at the mercy of the touring
shows and exhibitions and we're going to
have to get them to come down to the
bottom of new zealand
so that package has to be quite
attractive we haven't got to that detail
yet
but that will be another risk on this
on a slightly larger building
but i i guess the point i'd leave you
with is our advice around the
differences between option two and three
around meeting the vision and the
critical factors hasn't changed either
they're both going to be
we'll do them both right
um well we only do one right sorry we're
not going to build two museums
but
we will do it right
we haven't begun design but if we get
the budget envelope correct and you send
us in a direction we'll deliver
thank you councillor clark i see your
hands up but i've got two others who are
just uh who we haven't heard from as yet
so i'll go to them first councillor
scout then councillor pottinger thank
you chair um i'm a bit perplexed to be
honest just could you
clarify me the number of ratepayers we
have in the in the city
25 000. and we had 120 submitters is
that correct
120 submitters is that correct 111
i think 111 on the museum
111 of which some were positive and some
were negative would that be fair
i'm actually not i don't actually
understand why we're having this
conversation
well that's part of the process that we
work through it is but it's a there's a
very clear message
our community's actually spoken
not your feelings thank you councillor
pottinger being councillor sopa uh
through your chair um question is for uh
steve
um and the question is regarding
the the size difference uh the square
meters difference between option two and
option three would that impact on two
key
revenue elements of a new museum that
being a cafe and a retail store because
i know they are prominent in museums all
around new zealand so if you go
if you
don't go for the two
and went to three is that impacted on
uh simple answer is yes it will be
impacted on
it'll be a smaller square meter rate
in both cases and if we haven't
determined the operating model on that
whether it's a lease
or in-house
i think in the model we do have a lease
just to help round out the budget
we need to come back to you on that
exact operating platform but yeah square
meters will be smaller and so the
potential to fit more people in and sell
more things will be slightly reduced but
it won't i don't think it'll be a
significant because we're talking a cut
across the entire facility okay so the
impact will not be
half the retail area and half the cafe
it may be look you know percentage white
because that is dramatic
we we haven't gone through the design
process in exactly lining up how much we
allocate but we recognize that to create
a destination you need food and you need
a retail opportunity there too so
they will be different
too
is largely unconstrained
uh three will be constrained but we'll
be a bit more flexible about the floor
space so
as well as the square meter which
obviously then the revenue which will
help pay for the thing would be
constrained as well
because theoretically you
you couldn't make as much you couldn't
turn over as many people and you
wouldn't have the the obviously the
statues of tuataras and
and old old museum replicas for sale
yes
technically right um again that will
depend on the operating model that we
come back to you with right thank you
councillor soper
thanks mr mr chair um funnily enough
through you mine was also a square
meterage question um and it's partly
based on the consultation events i
attended
um
in my own reading of the various
submissions and the online submissions
both the new
options option three and option two
were larger proposals than the current
museum
it seemed to me in the consultations i
took
part in
that
when that was pointed out to people
that option three was 400 i'm rounding
things up here option three was 400
square meters larger than our current
museum
and option two
was another 600 meters larger
that a lot of the people who then fed
back to me
um
didn't think there was that greater
difference between the two did we convey
enough
that both those options were
larger than the current option i suppose
is what i'm asking
because i did
find a lot of confusion and discussing
that with people that
many people thought option three was a
smaller option
until i
went through the actual statistics we
had been as councillors provided with
did we convey that clearly enough to
people
i think that's a fair point councillor
that we could have done a better job in
comparing
the difference between the two new build
options and the size
of the existing
building it is detailed in the
consultation document and was discussed
there
i get again like the risk factor
there are so many different factors in
relation to this project which i think
also the feedback from submitters on all
the different details underneath that
they're interested in shows
that um
it's hard to pitch a clear
message and get all the details right
all the details were correct and out
there
but did people pick up on them
thanks it's difficult to shine a light
on every subject counselor clark thank
you for your patience
thank you just a follow on um from some
other questions
in relation to what rhiannon said and
what uh
evelyn said as well um
i think rhiannon you stated that you
thought the law of submission um that
due to covert
and possibly because people had already
shared their views which is what you
said
um is it a fair reflection that maybe
people had shared their reviews on the
long term plan on the options
and felt they weren't listened to
and therefore didn't participate the
second time around
so that's one issue you might want to
comment on it the other issue is i think
that's a rhetorical question knobby and
i'm not sure how we could expect brandon
to answer that in good faith
one other issue in the
in on page seven on the report on page
157 of board books it it talks about um
what is this museum is it an indecable
museum or is it a
a regional southam museum and it's the
latter that's the advice we're given and
so that begs the question that are we
paying a disproportionate share of the
new museum and the ongoing optics costs
when other councils should be
contributing more than what they pay
through their heritage fees
ah three years
the collection is
managed through a regional
contribution from the councils and
um we've i think we've progressed on
that
i we're not in a position at this stage
to comment like i can't comment on the
council i don't know clear if you wish
to make any statement on that claire
please
mr chia my advice to that question is
going to be
uncharacteristically blunt
if you wish to pursue a contribution
from southland and gore
other than the regional heritage rate
then the project will stop in its tracks
and
we have got the clarity around the
museum
trustee now
uh the interim board met on friday
and the work around appointing a new
board
skills-based board will commence in
about six weeks
but if we were to now go to uh other
local authorities
then there would be a pause put on this
which experience would tell us
would change the cost from 65 to 75
million
to 95 to 105 million
i think that invercargill needs to
determine whether it wants a museum for
invercargill and make its decision on
that basis
so just if i can
just add that is probably where the
previous projects had stalled as well uh
bearing in mind that both southland and
gore districts have their own
specific stories being told in in their
areas
i guess what has
been missing from what's been referred
to as the southern museum and art
gallery is any great reflection of
invercargill
and i think the opportunity that exists
is around reflecting where
invercargill's story sits and how that
sits in the context of southland so
while we talk about it as a south museum
it's it's really looking at it as a as
the museum of indica with part of a
collection that belongs to southland
reverend cook
um yes through you mr chair i think
that
it was something that the visioning
group was mindful of when they chose the
name to
it has no connotations of location or um
a particular area but it is inclusive of
the collection and the collection is
what is going to be housed in the
building
how what we name it
taking it away from being the south the
museum and art gallery may resolve some
of
that sort of angst about who is actually
paying for the building it's located in
invercargill and vocabula city has taken
ownership of housing the regional
collection
within its building and displaying and
showcasing it
the collection is available to other
museums in the region but the principal
pace of location will be in the
principal location of the province
and to me that does
i don't see what the contradiction is
but however
does that help you counselor clerk if it
is
a
non-um
location-based name does that help
oh i think it doesn't differ
and had the ongoing cost we should have
the i guess the ownership and i think
uh council ludlow gave a good
description there where he said
uh it needs to be or should be
in the cargo city museum but it does
tell the story of the wider region
okay councillors now we are actually
starting to get into the debate so i'll
pull it back and no that's that's my
fault i let that happen and took part in
it too um so i'll bring us back to any
questions about what
rhiannon's raised with
that part
if not
next item
okay so um
the next elements of feedback from the
community
were around the wider annual plan and
this message that came through
most strongly was around rates
affordability the rates rebate program
was raised in a number of times during
the hearing so i'll just note that there
are communications planned for this
month and next month in fact already
taking place on that program
um
the second element of feedback related
to capital delivery whether of the main
projects or of um
of the
general capital program
so i've just summarised here some of the
key points that people are making people
are really split
um between whether we should
proceed and get all the projects
delivered as fast as possible or whether
they believe that as councillors you
should trim the capital program in order
to make savings i will just reflect on
the fact that obviously this is a small
number of the whole
rate pairs that have submitted on this
issue
i'll just cover the issue of accurate
forecasting and management costs that
was raised by some submitters including
the invercargill rate payers association
so provided a breakdown in the report of
where the actual cost increases sit
and whether those relate to decisions
which council has made in case of the
museum and stead street
um
sorry not street stock bank
or whether they relate to increases that
have come through because of the
marketplace including the bank's home
water supply instead street stock bank
so at this point i'll just pause because
i believe there's an update on the
frank's home
yeah
through you mr chair look we just wanted
to provide a really early update for
council on the progress of our
procurement process and we've the tender
process has been concluded today sorry
to concluded today
as a result of this we're restricted to
sort of
the information that we can advise you
based on the advice from a probity order
and procurement team
but as a result of the tender process we
are signaling that we will need to
rephase or deliver the breaks on pilot
time and that this may include impacts
on the time required and possible budget
however we do wish to signal too that
there will be with a different delivery
approach enough funding to commence the
work
next financially and to continue this
work the following financial year as
planned
and once the team have undertaken a
review of the process and can refocus on
the delivery method we will come back to
you
to update you on the new proposed method
of delivery and expected completion
dates so i just wanted to give you a
quick update on that
thanks steve mr chair i'm not sure
whether i've heard clearly enough that
we may need additional funding but it
won't be for some time but i just want
to give you an early heads up
else was clear on that
anyone surprised
right
i guess the the good news is
the opportunity to stage it
will allow a greater chance for success
and for us to
cope with those changes financially is
that clear steve
thanks
questions around
those issues
no
yes sorry count sorry councillor clark
yes i've got a series of questions about
the rate affordability
for um
rhiannon or possibly for michael who's
around
um
and the suite of options that you put in
the report that you've considered
um there are some things for me that are
missing
in the consideration of how we might
fund that extra
3.15 which is
around about the 1.9 million mark
so i'll just run through those um
why we got no consideration
about an unbalanced budget which is
permitted by section 102 of the local
company
patricia do you want to oh
so we actually will be running an
unbalanced budget as a result of the
subsidy
moving
we didn't further want to run and
further unbalanced budget because this
actually results in us pushing
operational costs onto a mokapuna and on
to future generations to actually fund
the cost of actually not
living within our means now
so just to clarify the operational costs
so that what we require for the
day-to-day running of council
whereas the the stuff that is best
treated into general relation
intergenerationally are the larger
capital projects correct thanks
councillor clark yeah through new chair
and just just come back on that comment
look i i can't sit here and take that
comment to be talking about putting
costs
on to makapuna is outrageous
we've got 49.2 million dollars sitting
in our cash reserves we could take 1.8
million out of that
and and and get the extra 3.15 that
we're asked for if we bump rates up by
7.15
that's where the mock apprentice get
hurt because that rate doesn't just
impact on this year it compounds for
every year thereafter and so i just
can't uh can't take those sort of
comments sitting down so i guess
i still have the issue why we weren't
given that lever the other issues for me
are and we signaled this in a report
that i put forward on behalf of the
ratepayers group
there was no breakdown of personnel
costs so for those listening and
personnel costs are about nearly 25
of all the money we spend
um operationally every year in council
so that is a big big chunk of money and
it's a one-liner
so if you have an unbalanced budget so
we ran uh 1.8 million dollars short in
our revenue area we could during the
year find ways to trim back our costs
which is what most organizations would
do so i don't know why in this report we
don't have a breakdown on the personnel
associated
can i address that counselor um
partially the operational side of it
when it comes to to staff is is is not
our purview
but at the same time when we've got
quite a few
vacancies
around and
we've had
wage increases i'm not sure
where we can sit above that and and look
for trimmings in some senses where
there's vacancies that we have been
unable to fill and that is simply the
result of the job market that exists in
the country at the moment and
i'm not sure whether it's going to get
worse or better with the the borders
opening uh the fact remains that there
are positions that are unfilled and some
of those tasks have to be met by
contractors and that comes at a cost and
that's about ensuring the day-to-day
work happens so i'm i'm not sure where
in there
we can set a directive through this
process that's going to make cost
savings
yep just as a response to that chair um
personnel cost is not about salaries
it's a much wider picture than that so
it's not about trimming style i've never
suggested that and i appreciate the
vacancies that are being considered to
be held because annually also has some
other very large figures in it which we
can control so one of them is a crew
daniel lee
staff build up annual league as they go
through the year and if they don't use
it in a timely manner that sits on the
balance sheet and everybody that's
worked in finance knows that so that's
an area we could do better in i don't
know what our current reliability is
there because i can't get the breakdown
we have legal costs
and we have consultants and the
consultants can be very large as well
and so we could um put some constraints
around our spending in there and ideally
call back part of all of the 1.8 million
dollars
so i don't know why we don't have that
right now
and i guess the other issue is is there
are two other issues
when i asked recently about whether we
could use some of their
cash investments there was a gas from
the staff saying now we can't do that
because it affects our our net debt
so for those listening in net debt is
the difference between what you have by
way of debt
um and what you have sitting as cash or
cash investments in the bank and so yeah
and and it's about 90 million dollars
give a little bit of change
and so
1.8 if we added that by either by
borrowing more money or alternatively
not borrowing but using some of the cash
that 1.8
according to michael
at the last meeting would not change our
credit rating
it's not significant enough to do that
and that's been reinforced recently that
our cash investments have dropped from
53 million down to 49.2
so that's a
that's a
3.8 million dollar withdrawal money i
guess to be used for a range of costs
so that can be done
why can't it be done next year and and
i'm not asking
rihanna to answer that but it would have
been helpful in our report to look at
those levers so there's a range of
levers there and i think we've got a
very narrow look at that at this stage
so i'll go to clear i think some of what
council clark was referring to
uh in his first statement there is is
largely operational i'm not sure that
from a governance perspective it's up to
us to direct how leave is managed but i
understand
that in the broader sense
the outstanding leave balance has been
significantly managed down over recent
years is that true thank you mr chair
the answer is yes if i was asked
have we been paying attention to the
annual leave accrued the contingent
liabilities that show on the balance
sheet the answer would be that i've been
working on that since i came
mr giblin would confirm that gm's
receive an annual leave
balance for all staff approximately
every eight weeks
and we monitor for exactly the reason
that councillor clark has stated
patricia if i can come to you on the
second point that councillor clark has
always raised which is around net debt
and our ability to use uh some of
reserves uh to cover off that slightly
below two million dollars do you have a
response to that
so by using the reserves
to cover off the um to use this the 1.8
million it actually increases in
net debt or decreases it increases their
borrowing so that 1.8 we wouldn't be
able to use for to fund capital projects
we'd have to go borrow
that 1.8 so while we have the cash we
use the cash
intermittently with borrowing
so
that's how we would you would end up
having to borrow for it anyway it would
decrease our interest revenue and
increase our interest expense
thank you
so uh just
just a response to that because i'm not
sure i'm happy with that um it doesn't
affect our credit rating we've already
had that confirmed and it's all we want
to say well we don't want to take money
out of the bank because we might need
that at a later stage given that we have
our ability to borrow from the local
government funding agency
at much market much lower market rates
than probably any other business in the
country because of our credit rating and
the fact that we're a local government
um but yet we're quite happy to push the
rates up and those rates compound year
after year after year
um and so
um rate payers uh we're the cost of that
but the other issue that's not on there
is can we use borrowing could we borrow
some money for that 1.8 i would like to
know what uh patricia's got to think
about it
for a more operational cost as opposed
to um
okay capex
so
i
i guess
with my financial background i would say
borrowing for for operational costs is
not a smart move um for capital costs
yeah for for optics
no um but it is it is a juggling process
there you are mr it is a juggling
process and it's not one that i would
recommend that we borrow to fund our
operating costs
you could it's kind of like going into
overdraft with your bank without asking
them
okay sorry another question there
counselor oh that's that's me down on
that thank you thank you
sorry rhiannon
um just to note that there is an
opportunity
we have got all the levers kind of
discussed in the paper and we'll work
through them
so i'll just briefly touch on last two
specific issues that came up through the
consultation so that was esk street west
so just to note um
that that feedback from the local
developer around that new hotel
um
there are some options in that area and
it's recommended it be considered as
part of the long-term plan however if
there were any functional improvements
that were needed by the developer at
this point
there is not budget to do those those
would need to be at the developers cost
and secondly the submission from the
bluff
from the south end sorry
mountain bike club
around the bluff moto pahoe recreation
precinct just to note that car park has
already been brought forward into this
financial
year coming up in order to support that
application um to the tourism
infrastructure fund for those projects
so that kind of just wraps up the
summary from the public and then the
rest of the report deals with the
options now for council to consider
thanks rhiannon um before we get into
the recommendations and i will go
through them in a in a kind of bitsy
manner i'll give um councillors the
opportunity to
to uh raise any issues concerns or
points from a more holistic perspective
that they'd like to make now i see
councillor pottinger champing at the bit
yeah um
what we seem to be discussing is so so
micro that
that it's we're
we're ignoring the bigger problem i mean
this year's annual plan we could sold on
a rates rise of 7.78 it's now been
revised
7.15
this was a final result after
discovered financial information and
this is the number we're deliberating on
today
in isolation one could say that this may
be a solitary speed wobble
and a long-term plan the road to renewal
okay you get this right we're back on
track and then
this is where councillor clark raises
the issue about the four percent
forecast rate rises
are they actually real i don't see this
as correcting the long-term plan and now
i believe the long-term plan is way too
ambitious
and it's actually fiscally unachievable
when it's consulted form
and why okay so we've got to to
the new museum
so most likely we'll go ahead
and the option two format which
um
leaves 20 million dollars
that is unfunded we have to find
uh what's the next project we have the
branksome pipeline which we've just been
updated on
it was budgeted in the long-term plan at
11 million it's now gone to 25 million
that's an extra 14.
we now have
adding in there which is yet to be
consulted on
streetscape stage 2.
there's 14 that's 14 million dollars
that's not even in the long term plan
we've also got the civic administration
building now this is quite alarming it
it's budgeted
at 16 million dollars in the ltp
yet
i was looking at the minutes of the risk
insurance meeting
from the 23rd of march
and it shows the forecast is now
27.9 for that
now that's a public document and it
shows they're forecasting the civic
administration billing at 27.9 but
that's not
they aren't the worrying factors
the worrying factor is bank interest
rates
now this report tells us that
a 0.5
increase in the bank
interest rate results in 1.25
on council rates
now this is not just concerning for
council borrowings
but
if you look at a holding company and the
debt that it has
a bank interest rate hike here is going
to impact without a doubt on our
dividends from them but also it's going
to
increase the cost of our city's
involvement in in city block
look agreeing today on a 7.15 rates
increase it's not going to fix anything
um
the whole ltp
needs to be revisited look there's
nothing wrong with being ambitious but
it's got to be affordable
and i've made a wee analogy here if if
council wants to get the public on board
with its future plans it needs to place
itself
in the public shoes
so we all know without a doubt
the basic household budget's been
decimated by food prices
and by petrol
so
what would a responsible household do in
our situation so let's take the branch
home pipeline
and call it an essential and very
expensive plumbing upgrade
and then let's take the streets cut the
streetscape upgrade stage 2
that's kelvin street
and call that decorative landscaping
and it's not hard to figure out what a
household would choose to do
on a restricted budget
i mean we're not here to change the ltp
today
but we are here to show leadership in a
way forward
see no doubt this council has operating
cost increases and i've seen them and
they're real
they can't be ignored and along with the
0.62
increase that comes from museum option 2
there are reasons for
an increase over that ltp's four percent
um
i i don't believe a forced four percent
uh
rates increase is going to help us i
think it will push put us backwards
but i would sooner look at and i was
fascinated by the
uh rates affordability benchmark and
that's the local government cost index
supplied by
burrell
and then plus three percent and that
equates to 5.4
increase
and i i actually believe that this is a
more acceptable
number for this year
now i'm not sure whether mr chair this
is the right time to move an amendment
to what we have in front of us there's
nothing to amend
um we've got some figures there that are
going to carry on so will we have an
opportunity to amend those at the next
meeting
i mean the figures i mean no i mean the
7.15
well you can amend that at this meeting
okay
so i would wish because i mean i was a
bit confused with the how the notes and
noting and the recommendations were
going
so i mean i'd like to amend
i'll go again and say you can't amend
something that's not there so okay when
we get to and and i'm pretty confident
we went through this earlier item 15
if you're looking at making suggestions
around an overall figure there because
that's where we start to mention some
numbers
that's probably an appropriate place to
do it well i thought we were actually
debating the report right now
we're debating the report yes but you're
looking to make an amendment on
something that
it's not on the floor yet
it's yet to come i can have a point of
order ruling on that place
um mr chair it might help if i offer in
a slightly alternative way of putting it
counselors what you've got in front of
you is a report
which
mr chair i have to say hasn't even been
received yet so in terms of discussing
it it might be useful if the upper was a
motion to receive the report so that it
can be debated
then from any counsellor's point of view
they can move the recommendations from
the staff in the report
or alternatives
and that's not an amendment that is your
right as the elected members
once
once something has been moved and
seconded
then anybody else who wishes to make a
change would be making an amendment
right now to assist the process before
you jump in
and i think it would be useful
if we moved recommendations one to five
i just hadn't finished that
sorry i just finished i've got a wee bit
left i hadn't finished back to your
notes
i look
the reason the reason i'm suggesting a
5.4
increase that
that is not going to obviously pay for a
lot of this stuff
but that's not the problem the ltp is
the problem
and i would only move
when the opportunity comes
to go to 5.4 on the proviso
that
the new council in the trinium
revisits the ltp at the most practical
time possible that that's early enough
okay so those two go hand in hand
together
it's not a one-off fix it's the bigger
picture and if anyone thinks that
uh whereas 64 million dollars of money
we don't have for the ltp is a good
thing with that and that's not including
interest rates we've got some serious
stuff to consider thanks thank you it
would be
useful when we get to that point if you
can indicate when if we're looking at
reducing
the overall increase to 5.4
where we're expecting to to make those
savings um or i'll give some indications
on the areas where council would prefer
to
so yeah but we're talking about
the annual plan for this term so if
you're looking at bringing down from 7.1
to 5.4
where's the magic we are running an
unbalanced budget yep that's when we
took some advice on that earlier about
the degree of unbalance that we want to
run
uh so
i'll come back to items one to five so
that's first of all receiving the report
so we can formally get discussion
underway
uh and
two three four and five are notes
moved by council admins and second
council or so but those that's open for
discussion
put the vote all in favor
against
carrie
mr chia i'd like to
um
move options can you drop the mask sorry
counselor
sorry mr chair i'd like to move
recommendation six with the
determination that we include option
three for
tianua in the annual plan
and my reason for moving option three is
that
when we balance the vision and critical
success factors that we're all very
aware of the community experience and
it's been emphasized today by our staff
that the community experience will be
very similar between both the more
expensive option two and option three
as well as the risks
and the financial costs
i am
of the mind to say that option three is
the much more prudent option for this
council to take at the current time
we've been told about the risks inherent
in raising 20 million dollars of
external funding
for option
2 as opposed to 11 million much more
realistically in my opinion for option
three
we have had
advice on the ongoing operational costs
that would be much higher for the more
expensive option two
than option three
and staff have confirmed
that option three
does increase the size
of our of our existing museum
option two increases the slice size
slightly more
but staff have also concerned that i
confirmed that a large part of that
additional size of option two
was to provide for the possibility of
hosting
international or nationwide
exhibits
of which we might end up having the
opportunity to do perhaps once
or twice a year maximum
with a great deal of additional staff
time and arrangement
for
probably very little feedback since
their previous experience would be that
those international exhibitions
do not tend to make money
so for all those reasons i'm
moving
recommendation six with option three
and i invite a seconder
secondary councillor partner
it's open for discussion
council amundsen
thanks mr chair
i think councillor pottinger has raised
a number of really good points and i
know that i've harped on about risk
before and uh his first point was around
the ltp being too ambitious and as i
recall through the ltp process we were
told that repeatedly that what we were
planning to do was very ambitious
and so
i think
we have to bear that in mind i think
we've also taken
a risk with the cbd block investment and
again a number of those risks have been
realized we've had to come back and
consult with our community
several more times we've had to change
how we approach that we've had to give
additional money to that project
i think the reality is
risks become real
quite often
and my concern is
that with option two that risk will also
become
real
therefore i would support option three
um i think
that what we lose is really only a small
amount of space
uh we've already been told
that
um
that you know it's still
a very doable project
within
that smaller amount of room
i think the only other thing that leads
me to
have to mention is around consulting our
community
and it has been raised already that the
community has supported for the most
part
the larger option the council's
preferred option which is not option
three
and i think we always need to bear in
mind that we have to take some caution
when we say
and speak of listening to the community
as the only thing we are supposed to do
as part of the consultation process
we do have to listen to the community
yes but we also have a responsibility to
look at everything else that's why we
are elected
and i think in this case
we are still getting a brand new museum
we are still getting fantastic spaces to
share our stories
with our community and the wider people
who might come to southland and visit
but i think that the risk is not worth
it
with going with our preferred option
because
we are in a really uncertain time
uh we have heard from people about
um the pressures that they're feeling
with rate increases and increases of all
sorts
um so to me it's really the only
sensible thing that we can do for the
benefit of our community
councillor clark
thank you chair um
yes i support option three as well the
smaller of the two i think it's an added
luxury to have international
exhibitions down at a time when things
are fairly tight the city and will be
for some time
unlike uh
councillor podger i'm not too worried
about the long-term plan going forward
and i say that because i think we have
some levers available to us
and so while i put it before that i was
uncomfortable about the
level of staff advice around the suite
of levers that we might have for op eggs
we also have
a
set of levers that we can use for capex
as well which is a capital stuff so just
to run you quickly through a couple of
those
no you've done that quite a bit thanks
we're familiar with the options that are
there it's really um we're getting into
the broader financials there it's really
about option two or option three at the
moment council you're okay with that
well i've got no choice have i
correct
we've had three speakers in support of
option three is anyone wishing to speak
in support of option two reverend cook
and councillor skilt and councillor
lewis
yes mr cheers
option two for me is not just because i
was part of the envisaging group and
therefore somewhat attached to it
but a purely practical terms
as somebody who has been through the
existing facility and looked at why we
are facing the issues that we're facing
right now
which is
disjointed buildings that were added on
and covered over and all those sorts of
things
because at the time that the facility
was imagined they thought they were
going to be able to do certain things
and it never quite worked out
i
really am concerned that
not just the debt that we're leaving
for the future if if one wants to look
at it that way
but the facility that we're leaving for
our grandchildren may be something that
they look at us and say why on earth did
you settle for less
because now
it's going to be
as much again to expand it as it was to
build the first facility and that might
only be 20 years down the road
i know that none of us can see for sure
what the future holds for us
and i agree that sometimes we um can be
quite
um
optimistic
in our predictions of how things might
go
but we can also be unduly pessimistic as
well
and i'm not sure this particular
facility is the one that we should be
pessimistic about
i think we should be optimistic about it
i think if
we um
look at some of the other facilities in
the city
that
how they're used now is not actually
how it was envisioned
at the time that they were built but
because
the vision was great enough for the
facility to be maximized as it is now
and i'm thinking of stadium for example
that there it has provided opportunities
for this city
that were never thought of when the
building was designed
um it's been how it's been operated it's
been the imagination of the people and
it's been how they've engaged with the
facility that has expanded how it is and
this is what i envisioned for to
that's my hope that it will provide
opportunities but it also will provide
for the first time a proper showcase
for the heritage of my ancestors
and that is something that i i strongly
urge you
not to compromise because we've always
been compromised
with the optimum version there will be
no compromise required and that i think
is why i am speaking strongly in faith
of option two thank you thank you
councillor scout thank you to you
cheering i can't of endorse the comments
that just been made
um with option two i'm a huge supporter
only for the historically being involved
in a form of the industry and i've
spoken about this before
with the facilities that we have built
in the city
and for some period of time with all uh
respect to all previous councils we've
lived in a time warp and we haven't made
improvements
we've had opportunities but we haven't
done that that's why we're in the
situation we're in today
we haven't made those bold decisions as
a council around our facilities the
swimming pool being a classic example
three chops were had at that we didn't
get the civic theater right
for whatever reason we didn't get the
stadium right the first time we got it
right the second time and look what
that's created in the sense of
the opportunity for our wider community
going to option two the extended space
is the is the key
and there's some positives and negatives
as we know but that's the money part
that's the actual gold coin in those
exhibitions that's where the money will
come
because if we bring in an international
and national touring whatever it may be
whatever it may be
we can charge and gain some income
stream from that that space has to be
multi-purpose multi-functional
changed up which is going to be what is
planned to be
it's a massive opportunity
but we have
example after example of facilities in
this city
that have been built and we've
undercooked every time
so we have to have the vision if we do
nothing else
we're going to have a museum for a
decade that our young people have not
had or been in
a decade
seriously
and we use our figures we use our
consultation figures 20 000 plus rate
bars we have 120 submitters
and we challenge ourselves and we
flip-flop when it suits us we flip-flop
on figures when it suits us
seriously
we have one opportunity i can only
endorse the opportunity we've got we do
not want to be won't be us
but that next generation of councils
sitting here and saying hey we were too
small we didn't build for the future
build for the future
if someone had told me that seventy
percent of the income from stadium
southerners from entertainment
i would have laughed at them well that's
the figure
that's what has been created by
opportunity
opportunity this is our opportunity to
have something very special not for a
rainy day
but for a really fine day where
everybody comes it's not a rainy day
project
this is a sunny day project this is our
goal this is our new opportunity
thank you just before i come to you
councillor lewis and i'm i'm keeping
from a standing orders point a tally on
the fore and against and we've got one
more who can
speak in support of uh option
two
um
it's worth pointing out that both option
two and option three
are larger than the current
space available and i think we should
also keep in mind that the current space
also includes storage and that's being
shifted to um to to offsite so just
around perspective for both those
options councillor lewis thank you for
your question i try not to be too boring
when the first museum foundations were
put down
it was considered big enough
when the alterations were done it was
then considered
necessary the third operation the
alteration is done and so on and so on
i'm very scared that we will be lulled
into doing a substandard
and that's i don't mean to degree of the
planning or the construction but as far
as the demands of of exhibitions
i'm dead scared we'll go down that track
do it once do it right
there's an odd state perhaps do it once
do it correctly maybe grammatically
slightly better
um
there's an old saying um
aotearoa we seek higher things since
we're talking latin phrases earlier i
don't mean about higher rates
but i'm talking about higher quality
hard
and better storage facilities higher
better exhibition facilities
so i'm strongly in favor of option two
as i have always been thank you
thank you councillor uh councillor
pottinger you indicated you wanted to
speak you're in support of option three
yeah i seconded option three but what
i'm doing is um actually have an open
mind and the discussions that have been
you know for and against
and
the
the thing is that without a doubt option
two is it would be the one to go with
this i mean we've talked about it before
we debated we debated everything on the
uh
when was it 23rd of march 15th of march
we debated that
and it was all around the table but
there's some resounding figures that are
coming towards us now that we have no
bloody money um and now when you're
trying to balance stuff
uh and choose to fly first class or just
get there an economy you know i mean
this unfortunately we are really faced
between a rock and a hard plate about
something that we passionately want
and knowing
that we are really going to face some
terrible times with money that's no
there's no question about that i've just
pointed out 64 million dollars we don't
have
so it's great to have the passion and i
love it
but
how do you how do you separate
trying to be fiscally responsible
and at the same time deliver a drink
that's why i see the ltp needs to be
revisited which could potentially
potentially allow option two
and work it that way but we're not doing
that today unfortunately so that's why
i'd like the new council
to actually for somehow we could hold
two or three
and let the new council work the ltp and
see
what could happen then and they could
they could go through it and they'd be
doing it all over again a lot of hard
work
but for us to make a decision right now
this doesn't seem right
well you know some of us are making
decisions based on money other people
are making decisions based on passion
and and i don't think you can balance
the two and that's why
um so just my last point is that
now if we go two or three does that
carry through again to the 14th
to be altered on or are we are we really
selling the fate of the museum right
here and now my intention is we're going
to seal it tonight
yeah well i don't think that's a good
idea i really don't because a lot of us
deep down one option too but a lot of us
deep down want to want to keep the
finances tight so i think it's an
impossible decision
so to that because i'm i'm going to
speak in support of option three
which might come as a surprise since i
was the person who floated the idea of
putting option two as the preferred
option for for consultation
but
i guess part of the responsibility and
the oversight that i have as chair of
ppp is part part of our suite of of
operations is finance
and and
councillor pottinger's right we and
councillor amundsen we had warnings
when we went into the ltp process we
have seen cost escalations over the past
12 months there is stuff around
say for example the opportunity to gain
revenue yep shops and cafes absolutely
work touring exhibitions
in the museological sector are
challenging and with the stuff that
the previous smack had
none of it made money um so that that is
a challenge that's not to say you can't
create some things but it's very
difficult to rely on and we're in a
period where
we have listened to submitters talking
about
the the cost of living increase
particularly in a world that is coping
with covert and a
military action or whatever you want to
call it in in russia and the ukraine
that's shoving the price of oil up and
all costs are going up and one of the
few things that people have an
opportunity to have a gripe about is
their rates because we give them that
and it's a
time now that we've got to
pay some attention to it and some
attention in this sense is about making
a more
cautious
choice which is an around option three
option three i think is about setting a
price
but not closing things off and
and
reference was made before to splash
palace well one of the things that
happened when the original splash palace
was being built
because the scot the costs started to
blow out
as they trimmed off the the seating area
and later on when the place was up and
operational and as funds became
available they were able to be clipped
on and i think it's that kind of
innovative design that
is an opportunity that we're going to
have to look at and taking on option
three and getting us to a point where we
can get something because i'm acutely
aware of how long the place has been
closed and the feedback from people
to getting something open
on the site and then being able to add
and enhance it as affordability changes
so that's why i'm supporting option
three
with a heavy heart at this stage
i can take one more supporter of option
three councillor lush and just actually
before i come to you i think it's
important because you weren't here for
the hearings that we just confirmed that
you did have the pleasure of sitting
through the peter jackson length video
of all of the hearings and you have read
through the submissions yeah question
question be on it if you like um a
pleasant three and a half hours spent
this morning watching all of that so
thanks for asking me about that um yeah
i'm in favor option three because
obviously
you've known from my criticisms of the
vision statement
i don't think it showed the vision that
we needed
i don't think
and i think the hard work comes now i
think the hard work comes now otherwise
we're going to have a museum that's free
some of the museum we've got
um it doesn't seem to me to show
a new direction or something to attract
people here or to really change the
narratives around invercargill
so i think
small and punchy
is the way to do it i think the big one
i've sat here and talked to the people
about the visiting exhibitions uh they
couldn't tell me anyone so it could be
coming down here that would be perhaps
ones that hadn't been seen around the
rest of the country so i didn't see
the visiting
exhibitions being
things that would draw tourists
to invercargill
so i think the whole thing about it
being a tourist thing perhaps is not
quite right
um i also think in some ways that
what they have done with hawakituya has
been fantastic and whether
you know unfortunately not a lot of
people are going to see that
but i think that's done the visual arts
perhaps better
than the pyramids done them so i think
that we've got that there during the
time the museum is constructed and
perhaps into the future would be a very
very good thing so i'm in favor of very
much of the storage but i think the
smaller museum at this stage
is the right one to go for i think
providing we get the right people to
give that vision for the new museum i
think i think this is all very fine
talking about the funding and stuff like
that but i think the real hard work
comes now i mean because if it's just
going to be many many dings and lolly
cake you know i just don't think we got
any interest in it we need to actually
and sometimes i think it's the external
people that can really see the stories
that the world's interested in i mean
bearing in mind with burt monroe it
wasn't until the movie came here
that invicago really celebrated that guy
and i think that's really important that
we actually get that overview and get
the right stories not just the stories
we've always been told so i think we can
do that with option three so that's why
i think that's the right thing to go
with
thank you
so procedurally counsellors and your
worship if you're going to speak in
support of option two i'll allow it
i was going to sit on the fence
[Laughter]
no one's spoken in that particular arena
your worship so i'll give you the
opportunity just before that um
councillors i think i should let you
know it's my intention to adjourn the
deliberations soon uh once we've we've
taken a vote on this and it is a heavy
vote that we'll be casting um because
i'm aware that several people have other
appointments that they need to get to
and we because we've still got the
financials to go through there we will
reconvene those deliberations on the
31st so just as a heads up you will be
receiving a meeting appointment my
apology for spreading that that out this
is a process that in the past we have
dealt with these workshops sorry point
of order 31st of what 31st of may
so next tuesday
that's a question it's not a point of
order
um
so that's procedurally where i'm going
to go okay just so that you're aware you
worship
on the fence
i think that um
it's
one of those issues where where we just
don't know still we don't know what like
i was talking to a farmer's group
and they said we produce food
this country needs this world needs food
and
just the ukraine a third of the world's
grain comes from that small country
and so small countries are sort of
important and making sure
that people can eat
it doesn't really matter about it
whether you've got a museum or not in
your city if you're hungry
and
we have never sort of experienced that
really except during the great nutrition
new viruses are coming and
some of them have got really nasty names
and we haven't
completely resolved that issue
and
issues we think we'd all be united like
um
really
difficult
issues
we just
are learning more and more about them
like we always thought
earthquakes would be catastrophic
and then you sit down and watch the news
and this lovely little fishes floating
swimming around
and the volcano had no impact on the
environment
so there's just too many unknowns for me
and i think we should
put it off until the next
council they're gonna have to pay for it
we'll raise the money for whatever
option we go for
and we don't want it to look like we're
just taking advantage of
a um
quiet period
thank you your worship
counselors
is anybody else wishing to speak who has
not already spoken
i see you've got your hand up councillor
clark but you've had the opportunity
i'm going to test the meeting and put it
to the vote the the
motion is
we support option three
all those in favor if you could please
raise your hand
i'll take a note
uh counselor clark are you in favor of
option three
you've just muted yourself knobby
through your chair i'm not prepared to
vote on this because i've already said i
don't think we have adequately thank you
one two three four five
i'll come to abstain shortly just so
that we've got a
number those against those for
those voting against emotion can you
please raise your hands
i'm sorry mr sorry i'm gonna have to go
thank you you can put your arms down um
we're gonna have to go back to the those
supporting the motion because i'm not
sure that we had an accurate count uh i
know
right those those who are abstaining if
you could indicate now please
this is your moment you worship thank
you
two three councillor clark as well
yes
so the motion is carried
okay
that brings us to a quarter of the six
which is where i'm going to adjourn the
hearing um
look councillors i appreciate that that
last item was
was not an easy one and we're actually
only halfway through a really difficult
process but as i was starting to say
before before i got sidetracked
this is a process at this point that
we've normally gone through in a
workshop but we're having the debate in
public because we want to be transparent
and we want to make sure that everything
is is covered off we've still got some
pretty significant financial issues to
to go through and as i say we will be
reconvening uh next tuesday the 31st
thank you to the staff
for your participation thank you
councillors this
uh meeting is adjourned
thank you
you